a fifty-year-old tennessee teacher
accused of kidnapping his teenage
student is under arrest after more than
five weeks on the run tad Cummins was
arrested at a remote Northern California
cabin yesterday he disappeared with
fifteen-year-old Elizabeth
Thomas in March prompting a nationwide
manhunt Carter Evans is outside that
cabin in Cecil Ville California with how
Thomas is doing Carter good morning good
morning Thomas is safe and she's
expected to be returned home to her
family in Tennessee today now they were
staying in one of these two identical
cabins here behind this crime scene tape
we are in a very remote part of Northern
California just about 60 miles from the
Oregon border now investigators had
tracked comments to this cabin they
surrounded it and when he emerged they
quickly took him into custody after
traveling some 2,500 miles over the
course of 38 days teenage student
Elizabeth Thomas is safe and her science
teacher tad Cummins is under arrest she
will soon be on her way back home tad is
in custody of law enforcement facing a
set of charges that could keep him
behind bars for many years the two had
been the subject of a nationwide search
since March 13th when they disappeared
from kully oka Tennessee two days later
they were seen in Walmart surveillance
video some 600 miles away in Oklahoma
City police declined to answer questions
about whether Thomas left with Cummins
willingly she's a young girl that's what
the grown man he needs to be held
accountable for kidnapping this girl
after traveling from kully ouka to
Oklahoma City they drove more than 1,800
miles to Cecil Vale California on
Wednesday a man in the area recognized
Cummins vehicle from an Amber Alert and
notified local authorities the couple
was tracked to this small cabin after
this man called 9-1-1 someone showed me
a picture i was like that's the guy
sheriff's deputies arrived at the cabin
wednesday night but they waited until
9:30 Thursday morning for Cummins to
exit he was arrested without incident
they found two loaded handguns inside
the building
mr. Cummings made a spontaneous
statement to me at the time that we took
him down that
investigators say Thomas's reaction was
more emotional as she came out of the
cabin during cummins arrest it was a
very traumatic experience for her the
two obviously have a relationship and
her response to us kind of escalated up
and down now the Thomas family lawyer
says Elizabeth's parents are just elated
awaiting her return today as for
comments he is going to be in court
today here in California for an
arraignment he's facing multiple charges
including kidnapping and sexual assault
and Nora he could face a mandatory
minimum of ten years in jail Wow Carter
thank you I think we're all glad it's
over and that it ended safely that
everybody is okay and you know it's
interesting for him to say I'm glad that
it's over to just 15 years old so much
that's so much for that girl to go